bom eu quero compartilhar com vocês um
pouquinho do que é meu dia a dia eu
começo dizendo que eu sou um cara de
muita sorte
eu tenho o privilégio de trabalhar com
aquilo que eu amo e que desde criança a
minha paixão foi difícil os prédios e eu
tenho a oportunidade de trabalhar com um
negócio chamado greenbuild em
construções sustentáveis ea idéia é
compartilhar um pouquinho com vocês
sobre a nossa história a minha história
quando nós pensamos em edificações é
provavelmente a maior aquisição que você
vai fazer na sua vida é o seu
apartamento à sua casa à sede da sua
empresa sua clínica ao seu consultório
ea você compra esse empreendimento sem
saber o quanto ele vai consumir que
impacto que ele vai gerar você comprou
marca um saque em um chip se uma latinha
de coca-cola e você sabe o quanto que
tem ali de carboidrato quanto que ele
tem só de contas tenha lhe de açúcar
mas quando você escolhe a escola que vai
atender os seus filhos você não sabe
qual é a qualidade do ar dentro você não
sabe se a água é uma água saudável você
não sabe se ele vai sentir conforto
térmico ou se ele vai ter uma qualidade
acústica que não vai distrair ele dá
lição green building em construções
sustentáveis tem esse propósito
como é que eu construo é difícil que
consome menos energia que consome menos
água que fornece um ambiente mais
confortável e saudável e como é que a
gente usa recursos naturais de uma forma
inteligente como que nós como
engenheiros fazemos mais e melhor com
menos
e essa é a história que eu acreditava
que ia ser a minha vida quando eu estava
fazendo universidade
quando eu pensava em edificações ea
possibilidade de trabalhar com algo novo
windows em construções sustentáveis novo
horizonte a mais e melhor com menos o
que eu não podia
imaginar que queria ter a oportunidade
de trabalhar em edifícios altos
suficientes mas antes deixa eu explicar
um conceito para vocês
um grupo de arquitetos engenheiros 25
anos atrás queriam fazer mais e melhor
com menos e o mercado não respondia por
que é natural as pessoas serem
resistentes à mudança
a certificação leed leadership in energy
environmental design ela vem pra fazer o
que me dirigi recompensar desde
criancinha você é programado para
responder ganhar estrelinha toda vez que
você faz algo bom
bom se eu sou capaz de medir o
desempenho de uma edificação e eu
recompensa aqueles que se esforçaram eu
estou incentivando o mercado a se
transformar o objetivo de qualquer um
trabalhando com sustentável o propósito
e como que o transforma o mercado
alavancando esse mecanismo de medir e de
recompensar quanto maior o esforço maior
nível de certificação mar o nível que
você chega se eu tenho um esforço bom eu
tô chegando no nível certificado prata
ouro platinum até novembro do ano
passado o mais alto nível de desempenho
é um edifício que consumir metade da
energia metade da água que um prédio
convencional e chegava na certificação
nível platinum
mas chegar na certificação nível
platinum é a mesma coisa que falar eu
quero ir pro amapá mais devagar
dirigindo em direção ao rio grande do
sul e eficiência é importante mas nunca
vai chegar onde a gente precisa chegar
que é zero como é que eu 0 o impacto da
construção civil a construção civil
representa 10% do pib global
um terço das emissões co2 a quantidade
de emissões na construção transporte
materiais e operação de edifícios é mais
do que o transporte indústria o setor da
construção civil tem uma grande
responsabilidade
como é que nós viabilizamos edifício 0
energia zero a zero resíduo
pra mim essa sentença resume como os
cidadões
eu quero ensinar para os meus sobrinhos
augusto francisco é na tag só aquilo que
você precisa e não esqueça de colocar de
volta
esse é o conceito 0 aplicada à
construção civil
pegue só o que você precisa ser
eficiente significa isso ea nossa
responsabilidade junto às próximas
gerações colocar de volta 0 não é só o
objetivo o técnico não é só um bando de
engenheiro falando consegui
é a maneira com que a gente assegura que
eu tô entregando para meus sobrinhos por
meus filhos dos meus netos aquilo que os
meus pais tinham como missão como
propósito me entregar mais oportunidades
do que eles tiveram mais educação do que
eles tiveram
eu quero que os meus sobrinhos estuda em
uma escola 0 que era o meu sonho quando
eu tinha a idade deles e que agora a
realidade deles
bom uma coisa que o senhor vai
surpreender vocês o brasil está na
frente desse movimento eu estou sem o
cronograma que eu não sei quanto tempo
está passando
o brasil tem o primeiro edifício
certificado leed 0 energia no mundo e
aqui no paraná
o brasil tem o primeiro edifício
certificado leed 0 água no mundo em
outras palavras de todas as
certificações mais de 200 mil
certificações leed no mundo quatro mil
delas são platinum duas são zero e elas
estão aqui no nosso estado
o primeiro escritório da pnl em curitiba
nós somos uma empresa de engenharia
outdoors é um escritório que gera no
telhado 100% da energia que precisa para
a sua operação primeiro criando um
ambiente confortável saudável para nossa
equipe mas também extremamente eficiente
tudo que eu reduzi de consumo eu deixo
de gerar esse é o caminho para
viabilizar economicamente e esses
projetos
essa nossa principal área de trabalho e
abastece até a bicicleta elétrica de
algumas das pessoas e isso que é legal
né o que a gente
chama de zero me ter gente avalia o
desempenho da nossa indicação de uma
forma simples e fácil
eu gosto de dizer que é uma maneira que
até a minha mãe entende porque zero ou é
ou não é eficiência energética e você
tem que contratar um consultor com a
pedir a ele para explicar mais 10 é
aquilo que consumir aquilo que eu gerei
a minha geração tem que ser maior do que
o meu consumo
a gente tem um cliente que falou guia do
ici o meu consumo subir for maior do que
a minha geração eu falei olha é a mesma
coisa daquele jovem casal recém-casado
chega na época de festas
a noiva esposa deu pra ele uma calça
jeans ele abusou do peru e tomar muita
cerveja chega em janeiro
a calça jeans apertada ou você vai
comprar uma calça jeans ou você entra
numa dieta
a melhor maneira da gente fala de
desempenho com as pessoas é tornar fácil
de ser entendido aqui os certificados
aconteceu em dezembro do ano passado
o próximo projeto é o euro business é um
prédio de escritório ele acomoda 1.200
ocupantes 1200 pessoas trabalham nesses
edifícios são 14 mil metros quadrados
ele trata 100% do esgoto não só água
cinzas às cinzas negras ele infiltra
toda a água da chuva todo o esgoto em
bloco em outras palavras nada vai para a
galeria pública nenhuma gota de esgotos
saae do empreendimento e ele usa uma
fonte de água alternativa ele não
precisa da sanepar já está operando
primeiro do mundo também e se faz só dez
dias foi recentemente é um prédio
escritório se mostra mesmo no mercado
imobiliário é possível o tratamento de
esgoto é feito no telhado são 400 metros
quadrados de brejo artificial
sabe por que um brejo artificial porque
replicar natureza é a maneira mais
barata de tratar a água esse prédio não
usa nenhum produto químico para tratar o
esgoto e só porque está no telhado
porque a gente simplesmente não tinha
área no piso térreo
o sistema de contenção de cheias é o
telhado o sistema de tratamento de
esgoto o telhado
a água tratada por essas plantas
replicando o que a natureza já faz é
utilizada no vaso
fechado há água potável vem de um poço
para vocês terem uma idéia só um detalhe
é uma lâmina d'água em cima de um piso
elevado ea raízes das plantas que fazem
o tratamento
o prédio está operando já faz três anos
apenas nove por cento da água consumida
pelo prédio vem da sanepar é um sistema
de backup
só quando falta a água que eles usam a
água da sanepar é um edifício que
consome 91% - água medido não estamos
falando em relação a um design é um
benchmark teórico 91% da água ali é
alternativa certificado leed 0 água
bom não estamos falando de projetos que
estão fora da curva
é isso já está acontecendo isso já é
realidade sem distribuição da coca cola
20 mil metros quadrados era energia zero
água parece pouco painel fotovoltaico o
tamanho do caminhão de coca cola durado
desse prédio
são 20 mil metros quadrados
a embaixada da noruega em brasília 0
energia à sede da rádio engenharia um
prédio escritório em curitiba
todos esses prédios já em operação e
isso não está acontecendo no eixo rio
são paulo não está acontecendo no eixo
nova york londres tóquio
isso aqui é a sede da cressol uma
cooperativa de crédito criada para
atender o segmento rural pequenos
produtores em francisco beltrão
le plat não dizer energia e está
acontecendo aqui a gente está
trabalhando no projeto da amic hakim
cascavel em outras palavras isso não é
uma coisa da capital isso não é uma
coisa da alemanha
nós estamos trabalhando no sicredi aqui
em medianeira ambos edifício sendo
projetados para serem auto-suficientes
em energia a sicredi também
autossuficiente nada e eu quero falar um
pouquinho de escolas e como brasileiro
eu particularmente estou muito orgulhoso
de duas coisas que aconteceram
recentemente na história da pnl
a gente começou fazendo a univali
univali universidade do vale do itajaí
três campus universitário da energia e
se abrigou aço já está em operação
um ano adventista na região
metropolitana de curitiba quatro escolas
adventistas retrofitados prédios
existentes se tornando 0 energia
trocando lâmpadas trocando ar
condicionado instalado no painel
fotovoltaico e mais legal florianópolis
anunciou faz uns 20 dias
o retrofit de 40 escolas 16 delas vão
ser autossuficientes e semana passada o
governo do paraná anunciou que o ano que
vem nós vamos sair trabalhando em seis
cidades do estado incluindo cascavel e
foz do iguaçu
trinta escolas cada uma dessas seis
cidades então no total 180 escolas sendo
retrofitados para serem gera energia e
significa eficiência energética trocar a
lâmpada trocar o ar condicionado
instalar o painel fotovoltaico e colocar
o paraná no topo da pirâmide global não
esse é um projeto em uma escala que
torna o paraná é referência no que diz
respeito a edifícios da energia para
concluir né
a gente adora trabalhar na escola porque
pra mim isso aqui é o que eu quero
ensinar como valor para os meus
sobrinhos né
no final das contas tem o desafio
técnico eu estou maravilhado então
podendo trabalhar com essas
oportunidades mas poder passar para o
meu sobrinho né
aquilo não joga um papel no chão cara
aprenda pegar só aquilo que você precisa
e devolver a hora que você terminar que
no final é essa é a herança que a gente
deixa para eles e hoje a gente está
muito orgulhoso da podendo trabalhar na
construção civil em deixar zero impacto
deixar do jeitinho que a gente recebeu
dos nossos pais ou melhor
obrigado
[Aplausos]